okay thank you everyone for coming and
thank you to Corpus Christi for allowing
us to use the auditorium I'll get
straight to it and introduce the
speakers so on my far right is Collin
brewer he's a retired psychiatrist an ex
research fellow at Birmingham he's a
medical journalist and author of several
books he's written for The Spectator The
Guardian and the new humanist journal
and he has a keen interest in history in
the history and origins of religions
alexsei corner to my right is an Oxford
University student here with us he's got
an extremely popular YouTube channel and
on which he discusses politics
philosophy science and religion to my
far left is Mahanagar job he's an
academic researcher and so asked in
London and he's also studied in multiple
Islamic institutions
I see Mohammad is a kind of public
debater he roams around London locking
horns with Jews Muslims Christians and
atheists alike and as I'm sure you know
will attest have you seen his YouTube
channel and there's a most productive
conversation who's had Abdullah an hour
and the Lucy is an international
activist for Islam analyst and Affairs
he's given extensive talks and written
articles rationally critique critiquing
secularism liberalism's secular
democracy and materialism he's also the
co-founder of the public discussion
forum the Muslim debates initiative and
that promotes open dialogue and critical
thoughts and without further ado I'll
ask one of the proposition to step up
supporting the motion Islam explains
reality better than atheism okay
[Applause]
the name of God the gracious the
merciful
like to faint Knox's forum and my fellow
panelists for facilitating this debate
and everyone here for attending I used
to be Christian my mother was Catholic
and my father was secular I went to a
Church of England school and learned the
basics of Christian belief however with
there being so many belief systems I
asked myself a question how did I know I
was born into the correct one would I
have been something different if I was
born and raised elsewhere I then studied
every belief claim or worldview I could
find to discover the ultimate
explanation for all things in doing so I
found that many explanations couldn't
account for many things that I could
observe or prove themselves false or
fell apart due to their own self
contradictions or contradictions between
what they say and reality for example I
encountered Trinitarian Christianity
which argues that God is both one and
three and that the infinite immortal God
is also a finite mortal man I
encountered polytheists who argued that
there are many gods some eternal some
who popped out of nothing
who are all infinite but have created
and finite human or animal forms suffer
ignorance tiredness and even injury some
Pacific island religions consider
volcanoes who created their Island and
whose sent sediments make the ground
highly fertile for cultivation to be
also eternal and divine I've also found
that many atheistic positions are not
any more special or more coherent than
these for example many materialistic
worldviews argue that the universe which
we see is for which is finite limited
and changing is also somehow infinite
and eternal at the same time you just
can't see it
other atheist positions argue that the
universe ultimately popped out of
nothing
or b8 with precisely measured amounts of
energy but no cause to determine that
measure of course there are also
atheistic world views like types of
Buddhism which goes to show that atheism
doesn't preclude spirituality just God
when I encountered Islam I found
something different that Islam describes
God as a being of infinite or
inexhaustible power and who possesses
intentionality or will he has no human
or animal attributes forms nature's or
appetites Aslam teaches that God is
genderless does not experience Tidus or
ignorance and exists without peer surah
a class of the cry makes clear miss
Merriman rahim who Allah who I had say
God is one Allah who summit their
self-sufficient lamby Allah dwell amulet
he does not reproduce nor was he
reproduced while an Akula who could for
one I had there is nothing like him
which means he is without partner
because if there were other infinite
gods they would all limit each other and
would not be infinite or gods at all
this is the Islamic concept of God a
pure indivisible oneness a cause and
initiator for all things a divine unity
behind the multitude of created things
and it is the only explanation that is
without contradictions and circular
reasoning and does not need to appeal to
any mystery to hide faults it simply
doesn't have its lom's message to
mankind is to avoid the error of mixing
the infinite and the finite together and
creating false idols by attributing to
limited and finite things the attributes
that belong only to the Creator and
vice-versa
instead Islam asked mankind to recognize
the infinite alone as the ultimate
creator of all things
who is separate from his creation and
not like it is this a god peculiar to
Islam no anyone on earth today or in
history who worships an infinite
unlimited creator who willed all things
into existence and it does not resemble
any finite things or creatures worships
the same God we do whatever religion
they call themselves islam teaches that
it is not something new but mean
a reiteration of the same message that
has been repeatedly sent down to mankind
throughout different times and places
producing commonalities in many
religions throughout history now to
retire to the debate Islam explains
rarity better than atheism some might
say well atheism doesn't seek to explain
anything it's only a lack of belief of
God or rejection thereof but atheism is
denial of the existence of God carries
the minimum corollary that reality is
completely explainable without God and
they'd be wrong in my estimation there
are four aspects of reality they're only
Islam's concept of God can ultimately
and soundly explain while atheism cannot
do so without falling into self
contradiction and these aspects are
change matter finitude and specificity
atheism rejects the only sound
explanation for change if this moment
depended on an infinite number of
previous moments and movements
we'd never exist or get here if I were
to say that my opponents can begin their
speech after an infinite amount of time
they would never have the chance to
start their speeches as an infinite
amount of time can't end or even begin
if you could think about it likewise if
I asked a poor student my point they
know in particular for one pound and he
didn't have it and he asked another who
was equally poor and so on and so on
I'd never get that one pound until the
chain of students found at least one
student who had one pound to begin the
chain of lending and eventually get to
me now this is known as the infinite
regress fallacy which is the same as
asserting a beginning and no beginning
at the same time it is a contradiction
and therefore impossible the existence
of change and movement requires a first
mover there's no way around that
and if there is and if it is the first
mover it means it chose to move things
without being moved by anything else
therefore it has a will this is the key
characteristic of God whose name is al
moob T in the the initiator in the Quran
to atheism rejects the only sound
explanation for the ultimate basis
behind matter if matter gets is at
and characteristics because it is made
from something more fundamental than it
let's just say subatomic particles and
forces ultimately quarks and bosons and
these things are made of let's say
quantum vacuum energy or fluctuations
and in such thing or super strings one
of the other for the sake of argument
what is quantum vacuum energy or what
are super strings if they even exist
made of if something else and that's
made of something else where does it
stop if it has no end then nothing would
exist it's like saying a branch is held
aloft from the ground by an infinitely
tall tree or a pond has no bottom to
hold up the water
despite the water being at a specific
level the fact that anything exists and
continues to exist proves there must be
something fundamental that is supporting
all these things that itself isn't made
of anything else and has no parts and
therefore is self-sustaining the Quran
calls God a Razak the sustainer at
hearted the preserver our summered the
self-sufficient 3 atheism rejects the
only sound explanation for finite things
if something has size shape charge or a
specific characteristic what determined
these limitations in the first place
if it were determined by a finite thing
outside itself an efficient cause going
on forever it's an infinite regress
fallacy if it was determined by the
building blocks inside itself a material
cause going on forever into smaller and
smaller blocks
it's another infinite regress fallacy
the only possibility left is that all
forms and limited characteristics of all
finite things were ultimately created by
something that has no finite limitations
itself as ie something infinite which
has no limits that need determining by
something else and therefore is the
ultimate or necessary thing and it
creates all other things the Quran calls
god al Halep the creator for atheism
rejects the only sound explanation for
the specificity of finite things things
in the universe including the magnitude
of the forces of gravity strong weak
inner force and electromagnetism and the
amount energy contained in the universe
are specific to a certain magnitude
sized quantity
and quality considering that the
universe could have one quark more than
it has the question is what determined
it would be one way and not another
perhaps the conditions prior to the
universe's emergence shall we say led to
the conditions we see now but this only
shifts the burden of explanation further
along the chain
what then determined that precise
pre-existing conditions before the
universe that led to our universal media
the way it is if we invoke an infinite
chain of pre-existing conditions to
explain our current condition or the
condition or the emergence the universe
this is yet again another infinite
regress fallacy I'm afraid the only
remaining explanation is that something
ultimately chose or determined by its
will all things to be the way they are
the Quran calls God al misawa the shaper
Islam posits that God ultimately created
and sustained all things he is infinite
unlimited and self-sustaining and he
along he alone measured out the numbers
of things and apportioned all the
regularities or what you call natural
laws behind all things it is the Islamic
concept of God that not only explains
reality better than atheism but it is
the only explanation ultimately that can
explain reality that we see which does
not possess self-contradictions circular
logics or appeals to mystery or blind
faith the arguments of a theist in my
experience are no different to those
I've encountered from polytheists
Trinitarians or volcano worshippers
atheists just call their God the
universe which essentially is just a
bigger volcano
thank you
[Applause]
Abdullah can I have someone from side
opposition to go and speak thank you
[Applause]
well good evening everyone I'd also like
to extend my gratitude a also farm for
making this happen I did have some
things to say in preparation but one
thing that we have to understand before
we can even begin this discussion is a
core is the concept of the burden of
proof I did have some things to say like
like like I'd like I mentioned but I
think I'd rather just tackle some of the
misrepresentations I think we've just
seen of the position of atheism the
first is a rather important case which
is do we actually have anything to prove
as as non believers in God atheism as
Abdullah quite rightly suggests is
thought of by many as simply a lack of
belief in God and the point was raised
that no that can't be the case because a
lack of belief in God entails some
belief in the opposite or at least a
belief in in a universe that can be
explained without God this isn't the
case
atheism is a claim to belief a it comes
from the Greek a meaning without the Oz
meaning Ghana simply means living a life
without the influence of a God it's not
an active position to hold many people
would call it agnosticism because we're
simply saying well there's no good
reason to believe in a god but we're not
saying that we believe there isn't one
but agnosticism is a claim to knowledge
Gnosticism is knowledge theism is belief
I simply say I don't know therefore I
don't believe whereas the propositions
seem to be an obscene thing to have to
say that they also don't know because
nobody can know for certain and yet they
do believe and what we need to see
tonight in order to agree with the
proposition and have them win the debate
is the reason why they're able to take
that extra step that we simply can't so
let me explain with an analogy that
comes from a friend of mine called Matt
Dillahunty
who has given the example of a Gumbel a
jar of gumballs what is it what's
essentially happening here is we've got
a jar of gumballs and we have no idea
how many gumballs are in the jar and the
people to my right are pointing it and
saying there are an even number of
gumballs in that jar I say you have no
good reason to believe that I don't
believe you
and they say oh so to you money that
entails that you think there's an odd
number well of course it doesn't it just
means I don't believe that there's an
even number just because I don't believe
that there's a god doesn't mean I do
believe it there's not one and that's an
important point to make clear because it
demonstrates the fact that the burden
proof lies with the proposition if you
ladies and gentlemen are not convinced
by either side and the debate this
evening then the default position has to
be atheism the default position has to
be there's no good reason to believe
either way and so we simply don't
believe in Islam that's why the title of
the debate is something of a false
dichotomy but the burden of proof
certainly lies with the proposition but
that's not a problem because there was
some there were a number of arguments
but forward in an attempt to try and
fulfill that proof which it's worth
briefly briefly touching on for instance
when you bring up the point Abdullah
about matter you ask the question what
are super strings made of talking about
I presume the kind of quantum strings
that are thought to be according to
string theory at the basis of the
universe and you say essentially or one
of these made of them and what would
that be made of them would that be made
of well the answer is quite simple it's
I don't know and neither do you
and that's the point neither of us know
and so I'm simply saying that because we
have no reason to know what's at the
basis of this reality what's at the
basis of matter the best thing we can do
is throw up our hands and say until good
evidence comes along to believe that it
is due to some kind of divine
supernatural creator let's not do so and
certainly that's not instill that that
supernatural creator with certain
qualities that are naturally for faith
that you can't even you can't take that
extra step before you've made made the
first also in point of on the point of
change you talk about infinite regress
which is problematic of course the
problem of everything needing a cause
everything needing an explanation for
his existence whether you frame it as a
contingency argument or a cosmological
argument of course trivially applies to
the creator himself or course the
creator of course unless you adopt
something of a Kalam cosmological
argument that says that well we're not
talking about everything needing a cause
because of course like I say it would
trivially trivially include the creator
of the universe instead it's things that
begin to exist they need a cause it's
things that have some kind of that that
have some kind of cause that
brings them into existence fact of the
matter is we have no experience with
that you say that there are there are
atheists who believe that things can
come out of nothing there's no good
reason to think that something can't
come out of nothing people often say
it's ridiculous to suggest that
something can come from nothing you're
not all worried that a hippo has just
materialized in your living room while
you're out here but your living room
isn't nothing in fact there's no nothing
in the universe Lawrence Krauss has
shown that if you take away or written
that if you take away every piece of
matter from a finite space and you
remove not just the matter but the
radiation and and everything that we can
conceivably call matter it still weighs
something now that might be a practical
limitation perhaps there is nothing
somewhere and we just haven't been able
to access it or or create it by removing
the sufficient matter in the universe
but the fact of the matter is we have no
experience with nothing and so to say
something can't come from nothing is an
unjustifiable claim we've never had any
nothing to try it with in fact the only
time there was nothing if there was
nothing ever at all must have been
before the universe was created and so
the only thing that has actually begun
to exist in any meaningful sense is the
universe itself and if the argument is
that everything that begins to exist has
some kind of cause and so the universe
must have some kind of cause well
everything that begins to exist is the
universe so when you say everything that
begins to exist needs a cause you're
just saying the universe needs a cause
and the conclusion is of course that the
universe has a cause and that's the
definition of a circular argument now
that's the first point the the second
thing I'd like to do I'm not sure how
long I've been up in now I haven't got
over a good time five minutes okay so
about halfway through so let me let me
put you some of the things that I was
thinking of putting forward did I not
have anything to respond to in the
propositions case I'm sure that there's
going to be a lot of discussion of
metaphysics this evening there's going
to be a lot of discussion of arguments
for the existence of God
the existential arguments let's call
them and so I wanted to take a brief
moment to bring up what might seem like
in a relevancy but is certainly not
Islam teacher so there is an objective
basis to morality in the world that when
you say something is right or wrong that
is a true statement and that's as true
as something like the the proposition
that the Earth orbits the Sun it is a
matter a fact and that means that part
of the reality that we're trying to
describe with the Islamic world view is
moral realism
there has to be moral truths that are as
real as the metaphysical claims that
it's making well that means ladies and
gentlemen is that if you find moral
claims within the doctrines of Islam
that you don't agree with then you don't
agree with Islam so I want to consider
some of the moral elements of this
religion and see if it's something that
you would be able to throw away behind
there are of course many many examples
that I that I could choose from but one
of the most important areas and one of
the most often spoken about areas is the
treatment of women now this is
problematic because a lot of the time
people will point to practical examples
they say look at Saudi Arabia women
weren't able to drive until very
recently but this is ridiculous
Saudi Arabia can quite easily be shown
to not be a real is Islamic state and
it's very easy to make a case that
that's the state and not the religion so
let's turn to the doctrine itself let's
turn to the scripture what do we find
well there's a very famous verse in the
Quran and I'm sure this is nothing that
the proposition hasn't come up against
before but I'd like to hear some kind of
justification for these things and I'm
sure they'll be able to provide them the
in the Quran Sura 4 verse 34 I'm sure
you're familiar with is the verse which
I'll quote you and men in men are in
charge of women by right of what Allah
has given one over the other and what
they spend for maintenance from their
wealth so righteous are women who were
devoutly obedient guarding in their
husband's absence what Allah would have
them guard but those wives from whom you
fear arrogance first advise them then if
they persist forsake them in bed perhaps
this isn't the thing about women perhaps
this is just a thing about violent
behaviour just about striking people who
were disobedient and they're not even
disobedient to the husband but
disobedient to God if someone's being
disobedient to God then they need to be
set right and perhaps the only way to do
that sometimes is with physical violence
well okay if that's the case then let's
look at a comparison from hadith
reported by al Hakim on disobedient men
so this is in reference to why it's
talking and talking about their husbands
she should not beat him in case she is
stronger than he if he is more if he is
more in the wrong than she she should
plead with him until he is reconciled if
he accepts her pleading all well and
good and her plea will be accepted by
Allah well if he is not reconciled with
her her plea will have reached Allah in
any case so if a woman is disobedient to
a man or disobedient to a god
whichever frame you whichever framework
you want to think about it the first
thing that the wife should do if the man
is disobedient is to try and talk him
out of it and if that doesn't work it's
not a problem because I was gonna hear
it anyway but if a wife's disobedient to
a husband then surely he should she
should still try and talk her out of it
but if that doesn't work well then you
can strike them seems to be a bit of an
inequality here and that in quality in
equality is only highlighted when we
look at the rest of that same hadith
it's preceded by the following it is not
lawful for a woman who believes Allah to
allow anyone it is not lawful for a
woman who believes in Allah to allow
anyone in her husband's house while he
dislikes it
okay well back in the times that this
book was written men were primarily the
owners of wealth so it makes sense if
the man is Ian's property perhaps it
should be his decision he was allowed on
the property that's not so much a
problem but let's continue she should
not go out of the house if he dislikes
it and should not obey anyone who
contradicts his orders it's getting a
bit more questionable now and to finish
off at the very next sentence says she
should not refuse to share his bed and
you can take that to mean what you will
I'll remind you that if you find any of
this objectionable then you should find
objectionable the doctrines from which
they spring another thing I'd like to
talk about and I'm certain because I've
certainly seen this in each I'll respond
to this in the past and is something I'd
love to dive into it's the marriage of
the Prophet to Aisha
as certainly the Muslim members of our
audience this evening will be aware of
but perhaps not everybody Muhammad while
in his 50s married a young girl called
Aisha and I say young she was six at the
time 16 or 60 but six now of course he
didn't he didn't consummate the marriage
when she was six years old that would be
quite outrageous he waited another three
years until she was nine
the proposition has to defend the idea
that was ever morally permissible and I
think that's my time is that my time
well that's all I've got but believe me
I have more so we'll leave it for the
rebuttal station first day of Ramadan
for us and we're happy to have you
now come here Mian Abdullah lacks you've
come here to refute magic wait a minute
what did you say
let me say that one more time we've come
here to refute magic it's actually a an
interesting magic trick where there is
no bunny
there's no Hat and in fact there's no
magician at all it's the proposition
that something can come from nothing not
only from nothing ladies and gentlemen
but from nothing and by nothing the
Koran says I'm holy comb in Whalley
shade in a moon holy porn I'm Holocaust
are aware tea well a ballet opinion what
they created from nothing or were they
themselves the creators of themselves
now we've heard Alex today for the
second time I've heard him say this he
says that the universe may have come
into existence from nothing minute 14 to
15 in his video does the universe have a
cause he says when the universe came
into existence it well and truly came
into existence from nothing now wait a
minute ladies and gentlemen I have a
challenge that's an active claim he said
I'm here to make any active claims sorry
that is an active claim look at the
syntax of that particular sentence
you're saying the universe came into
existence from nothing
don't don't pretend to be passive oh I
don't know no you do know you're making
a statement either you know what you're
saying when you don't tell me how the
universe came into existence from
nothing and by nothing exnihilo
I want to know tell me how that's
possible metaphysically
ontologically cosmologically from first
principles give me the answer please but
it's interesting because in his other
video something from nothing where he
was debating the contingency argument
with a fellow American or an American
man minute 48 he says this listen to
this he agrees with the the radio guy
that was speaking to him that the
universe is a necessary existence who a
a minute wait a minute what's going on
here ladies and gentlemen what does
necessary existence mean and necessary
of a necessary fact is a fact that
cannot be any other way
two plus two equals four that's
eternally going to be the case so a
necessary existence is a turn it cannot
be any other way so even if the universe
is eternal how could it come from
nothing contradiction it's a
contradiction you can't have it both
ways my friend this is what atheism
leads you to contradictory set of
propositions either you have your cake
or you want to eat it what you're going
to do with it tell me now that the
universe come from nothing if so how so
that's an active claim is the universe
and necessary existence if so how so
that is an active claim is it eternal
just come up please don't pretend to be
innocent and agnostic number two you
could say no there's a multiverse or
there's an eternal fabric or there's an
eternal universe what a multiverse has
the propensity of being any other way
and I'm sure you study philosophy you
know what you're talking about a
possible existence or in a contingent
existence is defined by being able to be
rearranged in any other way if it can be
arranged in another way it's not
necessary it's possible or contingent
it's not necessary so a multiverse
cannot be necessary existence because it
can be arranged in another way it can be
out of existence so wait a minute this
is very important guys hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
you agree that there should not be ought
to be unnecessary existence if you agree
with me on that then you're not an
atheist because the necessary existence
is the Islamic definition of God Paul
who Allah who I say he is one and only
the self-sufficient be independent
meaning the necessary existence lamian
it well emulates he baguettes not nor is
He begotten meaning he's eternal if you
say that there's a necessary existence
you cannot say you're an atheist from an
Islamic perspective and from a
philosophical one moreover we have to
ask a question now we're talking about
Islam so why is Islam Allah different
from any other religion because Islam
talks about one necessary existence one
independent one self-sufficient not 3 &
1 1 & 3 not a triune God not a
multiplicity of gods a plethora of God's
not a pantheism and by the way I have to
make this clear now it was a bit of a
straw man argument because Alex came up
and says Abdullah said and the universe
has a cause he never said that in the
statement but he had this pre you know
written things we never used the word
course you can have a necessary
existence you can make it ontological
argument for a necessary existence
without causation at all there's a
difference between possibility and
contingency on the one hand or Nessen
necessity and causation you don't even
need to you can have it you don't you
don't believe in causation food universe
a fallacy of composition have it no
problem
you have to explain how there can be a
world with only possible existences how
can there be a world with only possible
existences if you say there can't be and
we're happy to say there's a necessary
distance you're no longer an atheist or
an Islamic perspective because you
believe in it independent
self-sufficient thing that everything
depends upon and that is the ultimate
explanation for all of all of existence
now a secondary point we need to make is
that Islam the concept of God the Tao
hate the monotheism is something not
only intuitive but is something as we've
seen that can be reasoned from first
principles ladies and gentlemen
and that's why already when we just look
at the concept of God so many of the
major world religions are ruled out
Christianity is ruled out
Hinduism is ruled out I would say
Sikhism is ruled out why because of that
pure monotheism that that respectable
monotheism that Islam has to offer
but in addition to that as Abdullah
alluded to the meta-narrative of there
being many prophets aforetime many of
them with the same message of Islamic
monotheism believing in one God
worshiping one God it's something which
can be seen in the religious books what
Abraham said what Moses said what do
they come and say even according to Old
Testament literature
calling the people to monotheism so
aslam also has an inbuilt system of
falsification works in a similar way to
science in many ways for challenges
which I'm happy to take questions on the
questions of artha or in a
cross-examination one if this book was
from other than God the for ancestor by
itself there would have been many
contradictions chapter 4 verse 92 number
2 the inevitability challenge try and
produce something like it and there is a
quantifiable way of doing so much we can
talk about in the question analysis
number 3 that Islam makes predictions
about the future and specifies time in
place and it's this is my claim it's the
only religion to make a series of
predictions about the future none of
which have not materialized whereas it
was anyone you want to mention who makes
predictions of the future at least some
of their predictions will be falsified
and I'm willing to be tested on this
test it is falsifiable and in fact this
falsifiability is even stronger than a
scientific one why because in scientific
falsifiability m
thing is susceptible to falsifiability
everything that's done now if I do a
scientific experiment now it can be
falsified but with a retrospective
perspective a hindsight perspective if
predictions have been made of the future
we can see whether those predictions are
right or wrong and we could talk about
those predictions of there's a book
coming out called the forbidden
prophecies by IRA that's going to be
something which details that case in
detail now the interesting thing is you
have a nihilist someone who does not
believe in existing - he's leaked
substantial nihilist whose cosmic
skepticism existential nihilist amoral -
he is an epistemological Nilus he
doesn't even believe the morality and
he's making a moral case today I mean I
don't know how this works
I really don't know he says I
subjectively value my liberty in one of
his videos the moral argument one hour
16 minutes tell me how from first
principles Liberty works is it not based
and predicated on a fictitious
hypothetical mythological state of
nature detailed by John Locke and Thomas
Hobbes and those individuals where's the
scientific evidence for that why do you
believe that why'd you bring the quality
John Locke established his equality on
the hedonistic principle and on a theory
of God now you're an atheist trying to
find from first principles why I believe
in equality we as Muslims don't believe
in second wave feminism
simple as that yeah there's some things
in Islam which are different for men
that women why do I say just find myself
to you you have to justify why that
equality of the six that Eurocentric
understanding of equality of second wave
feminism in the 60s that emerged is the
objective morality that's you that's an
active claim that you've made
you have to substantiate it but listen
to what he says in his video my problem
with Sam Harris the morality
can I finish off if you go to Somalia
and tell those women why do you put
those women in bags they'll accuse you
of cultural imperialism
so why you asking the women if they've
been put in bags what kind of discussion
is that what kind of sanctimonious
Orientals understand Authority is that
you have to first prove your morality
your objective your subjective Morales
believe in objective morality don't ask
me about morality you don't believe in
it prove it there's an active claim and
with that guys I want to say one last
thing which is that he made an egregious
claim in one of his videos called the
liberal hypocrisy of Islam he said Islam
is a racist religion and I will tell you
that Islam is the only religion in the
ancient religion in the world which
completely negates racism look at
chapter 49 verse 13 of the Quran look at
the Prophet said there's no virtue of a
black man or a white man I will not Arab
now he's got three options option 1 to
retract the statement option 2
yes option 2 to provide the evidence or
face public humiliation today and
there's no fourth option so don't make
plans about variety and about Islam if
you haven't even read the Islamic
literature and you don't know what is in
its contents sorry for the and or its
acquire you know performance but it's a
very strong it's a passionate topic for
us I hope I'm thanking everyone here and
I also thank cosmic skeptic for coming
and for once speaking to the Muslim
community rather than about them thank
you very much for listening
[Applause]
I'm a bit of an amateur at this these
guys are all more less professional I
wish I was a certain of anything as the
people on this side of the table seem to
be oh absolutely everything I won't
start by not singling out Islam
particularly because Islam is just one
of those monotheism's that seems to find
atheism terribly worrying they all
whether whether the theistic religions
believe in one God or many gods they're
terrified of people who don't believe in
any gods and when they have the power to
do so and in the case of Christianity
when they had the power to do so they
routinely tried to silence people like
me by at best by censorship at worst by
imprisonment exile or execution and
there's nothing particularly Islamic
about this Christianity was executing
people just for being the wrong sort of
Christian before Islam was a twinkle in
in Mohammed's eye and they continued to
do so until 1826 which was when the
Spanish Inquisition executed its last
victim here I want to approach you a
couple of worried Christians talking
about atheism in the 17th century one of
them was a both French theologians one
of them said I am afraid that atheist
writings will disclose thoughts to me
that would throw me into a fear from
which I would not be able to return and
his contemporary Andre Babi Yar said
that for such skeptics there is no
punishment violence at our for so dark a
crime even in our own relatively
tolerant country when Parliament was
open to people who were not members of
the Church of England yes who came last
first of all they let Catholics in about
1829 they let the Jews in about 1850
they let atheists in about 1880 so
Christianity no longer has any power to
liquidate people who question it and
almost everybody in Britain and most
civilized countries is pleased about
that I'll explain what I mean by
civilized in a moment Islam has not lost
that power not only that but many people
in Islamic countries and in some Islamic
countries most of the people are very
pleased that it has the power to do very
nasty things to atheists the Islamic
countries were the only ones who refused
to side in the part of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights in 1948 that
said that that deals with freedom of
religious belief including the freedom
to change your religion or not to have
one and that's why I think that such
countries are in one very important
sense not totally not altogether
civilized last year I was asked by the
professor of English at the University
and one of the more liberal Arab
countries if I would write an article
for his small Arab language departmental
journal on Sigmund Freud's use of
language it will be published soon and
I'm very proud it'll be my first work to
be published in Arabic but it has one
very important their mission soon after
I started writing it I thought I'd
better check with him whether it was ok
to mention that Freud was an atheist he
said if you do that they will
immediately closed down the journal and
possibly my department as well you don't
really persuade me that you get a better
grip on reality when you spend your time
trying to stop people from giving their
views on various aspects of reality and
when you outlaw discussion about what
reality might mean and whatever we mean
by reality
yes there are two broad types around see
what is historical reality which means
an attempt to find out what really went
on in the past and the other sold
reality is current reality things that
we can examine question now so let's
deal with historical ones first a few
years guys on holiday in Morocco and we
hired a driver to take us around and it
was quite a long drive he was he'd been
to University in Britain his English was
excellent and naturally enough we the
discussion turned to Islam and he was
very keen to tell us in his thoughts and
I learned from him that it is completely
wrong that Jesus was the son of God and
that he died on the cross now these are
the fundamental tenets of Christianity
you don't get any more fundamental than
that and he said that probably and this
is a certain amount of debate about this
in my Islamic scholars but it may be
actually Judas suitably disguised to
died on the cross now not being not
being a theist I I don't particularly
care which of them is right they cannot
both be right either Jesus died on the
cross or he he does not die of the
process of either he was Jesus or he was
Judas but they cannot both be right they
can however both be wrong and that that
is the problem when you start insisting
that things written in ancient documents
must be believed without any question
there is actually a lot of questioning
to be done about the origins of the
Quran there is very little documentary
evidence about for about two hundred
years
Christianity is bad enough because there
is nothing about Christianity dates from
earlier at about forty to six
years after the crucifixion and we know
how difficult it is to be certain about
events that happened 20 30 years ago
people have ferocious arguments about
the Second World War about various other
wars that have happened since so when
you're making claims with the kind of
certainty we have seen from this side of
the table about historical events when
even the history of the Koran is
shrouded in quite a lot of mystery and
when you threaten people with with
serious sanctions if they try and do
research on it that to me does not say
very much about your desire to get to
grips with reality it was not permitted
to do serious historical research on the
Bible until about the end of the 18th
century you could still be sent to
prison in Britain for denying the
Trinity as late as about 1812
but eventually in the 19th century
serious higher criticism as it was
called of the Bible appeared and now
people are very much less certain that
everything said in the nude in the older
New Testaments is actually true in every
respect put it mildly
the Catholic Church didn't allow that
until about 1941 and Islam does not
allow it still Islamic scholars have
found their careers seriously threatened
if they really tried to get to grips
with some of the mysteries of the early
versions of Koran and so forth so let's
turn now to how am i doing for time that
way oh all right
I didn't hear the halfway mark let's
turn very quickly then to reality as is
current
a few yes I got into some discussion
with a doctor magic at me
describes himself as spokesman for the
Islamic Medical Association of the
United Kingdom our medical ethics and we
I was interested about Islam's line on
abortion and he wrote to me saying
because obviously what are the issues in
abortion is when when does the fetus
become become human when does the fetus
be gained the kind of status where his
destruction becomes increasingly
important and he said at six quoting him
directly at six to seven weeks of
pregnancy the soul is breathed in in the
body of the fetus divine human life
starts when the embryo turns into a
fetus okay so that's readily clear it's
not a human being until until it turns
into inter fetus at this critical stage
is absolutely forbidden to interfere
with this new sacred life one can call
the fetus here a person a human in
divine however there's wide muslim
opinion in the muslim world considered
by many muslim scholars in the past and
some of them say that insolvent occurs
120 days after conception personally I
and other Muslims do not agree with this
view based on the wrong Arabic
interpretation of one sake of the
Prophet and then he said this important
saying of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him when 42 nights have passed over
the the north not far the fertilized egg
Allah sends an angel to it who shapes it
and makes a tearing vision skin flesh
and burns and then he says o Lord is it
male or female and your Lord decides
what he wishes and the angel reportedly
gives the reference and they had it so
there it is forget all that ludicrous
stuff about Y chromosomes and gender
it's Allah what does it it and maybe
someone should ask the Muslim Council of
Great Britain if they really want
someone like that advising the modern
medical matters yes I will intercept
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so so basically I think maybe my
colleague is used to debating perhaps
some certain Christians and
what-have-you
I'd like to think that perhaps we were a
slightly different breed in terms of our
approach or flocek approach I don't
think he dressed actually what I said
and I think straw man my argument but
for example I'll give example so I never
said everything that begins to exist has
a cause I never used that because the
you can always say well how do you know
everything does begin to exist and that
would require empirical verification
which is what I never that's why I never
said it in the first place I merely
posited that ultimately and I don't know
where the where this ultimately is I
just said ultimately there will be a
cause I don't know how old the universe
is maybe we've been through a couple of
you know six or seven big bangs and big
Crunch's and until getting to this point
of course universe is everything that
exists I merely said that at some point
it has to start somewhere because an
infinite regress would mean there would
be no change no creation nothing and the
same for things like what matter is
composed of I never made an assumption
that it is quantum vacuum energy or
super strings which lobby a lot of
scientists now doubt the idea of super
string theory bit of fantastical but but
I just posit those those two let's say
whatever you want the question all can
always be asked what are they made out
of what are they made out of if their
attributes come from what's something
what they made out of for example then
what can you you can what can they made
out of until you get to the point where
there must be something that's
fundamental fundamental substratum that
supports all year at his existence and
if it's fundamental and it's necessary
then it wouldn't be limited and it would
be self sufficient because it wouldn't
require anything prior to it or
underneath it or further more
fundamental than itself so these are
kind of the arguments I made but I guess
just to kind of reframe this discussion
in terms of what I mean
by atheism while I mentioned the term
atheism you're right atheism isn't a
belief but I posited that it carries a
necessary corollary something attached
to it which is if you don't believe in
God's existence not that you may be just
it's just your default no if you don't
believe it's God's existence that means
that your worldview does not require you
to posit God to explain things I mean
really posited that reality imposes
certain problems if you want to keep God
out of that discussion because
ultimately you can't explain cause
matter specificity or limited finite
things and my explanation isn't one
where I've known I know stuff because
I've observed it is that God is the only
explanation to avoid self-contradictions
and that's pretty much it like like I'm
saying if we take two and we add two I
know that this will equal four because
taking the premises the conclusion must
follow so likewise I know that the
premises are the existence of finite
things that's the premises so I know
that eventually at some point it must
follow that there must be a beginning
point a creating point start point and a
fundamental subscribe him that's
supporting all things even though I
don't know where there is where the
boundary that is that's my argument you
could you put that into the doctor form
in the deductive form Wow so two plus
two equals four is a deductive for Miss
apprentice and a conclusion it's not
deductive form to say there is matter
and matter must have a beginning what's
the what's the deductive argument there
well for example well it's the avoidance
of contradiction because Judas plane so
if I was to say two plus two equals six
right and six meaning what we what we
conventionally understand six to be we
know that was wrong because of
contradiction so my point was that if
you were to say well before before this
point in time there was an infinite
number of moments or movements I would
say we would never reach this point in
time because it would be a contradiction
asked the I think you know what I'm
saying you're trying to say you want us
to say everything that begins to exist
has a cause no that's not necessarily
the kalam that's not what I'm going with
saying is that if you the reason why you
can say the two plus two equals six is
false is because you're right at least
to a logical contradiction the reason
for that is because it's essentially a
logically valid argument with premises
and conclusions and you can identify
exactly how it contradicts you can put
it into a truth table and show that yes
it's tables precisely is it is a
tautology in you and you can prove that
deductively but there's no can you
highlight precisely what the premises
are and the conclusions are of your
argument here so it does it because it
does if you're going to say that it
leads to contradictions if you don't
agree with well it does because a new
uniform of an infinite regress is
basically saying that there was no
beginning and yet we're explaining
although there was no cause and we're
explaining the course of things were
explaining the beginning of things or
explaining movement so there was no
first movement but there is movement so
it creates a contradiction in terms
because in essence we rely on a
pre-existing state or pre-existing
conditions of movement and here
ultimately there is no business you're
saying there is no beginning to this
pre-existing thing there's just eternal
an eternal chain that there is no start
and therefore it's the same as say
nothing actually I'm trying to prove
that we regret so I've got one statement
too that can kind of summarize it for
you anything susceptible to additional
subtraction cannot be infinite okay okay
so that's it doesn't need to be a
deductive three-stage deduction that
makes it right so now I'm just given one
statement he what he's saying is that if
you have an infinite thing and you add
to it
then there's the absurdity of adding to
an infinite physical quantitative thing
so you'd have to disprove that statement
now we've made the statement anything
susceptible to additional subtraction
cannot be right cannot be infinite so in
order for you to to prove your infinite
regress if you wanted to prove it you
have to prove or you have to show how
it's demonstrably possible for something
to have infinity as equality as well as
addition and subtraction there as well
no idea so then you can't really make
anything I don't know but I'm not making
a claim that's the thing so then why I
were having this discussion because I'm
opposing your claims
well you can't oppose your claim is that
it the all claim is that it requires it
and I'm just asking you why that's I'm
saying anything that is logical
the idea that it is logically necessary
to have causation or that they call they
can't be an infinite regress no no I've
just said the wife says this the same
when I make anything susceptible to
addition or subtraction cannot be
quantitative quantitatively infinite yes
you have to you if you're reducing that
you have to disprove that how is it
physically mathematically or otherwise
how is it possible to have a
quantifiable infinite which is
susceptible to additional subtract as we
have to do I've just made the claims
brief the true and you failed to do the
answer the answer is that you're right
like these things are required okay
according to the laws of logic and
physics that are predicated on the
existence of the universe and we're
talking about the universe why is it
pretty clear on the existence of us
because can you prove it well no okay so
it's a possibility right nonetheless an
active claim which then it's not as
amazing possibly so you know it's not a
possibility if it's possibly true no
it's not possible true why is it not
possible because if the universe of
possible existence then it cannot
explain the existence of other possible
existences if if there is a necessary
did you gather Jonas on the page yes I'm
asking if there's no you can you just
that first this one friend to again if
there is a necessary being or occurrence
and that entails and which is what you
admit and that M and that entails yet
another occurrence no it doesn't intend
if it does if I may just say I think the
confusion is firstly I don't think all
things require putting into a logical
syllogisms yes I think it's necessary do
it I'm saying that it does when you're
making contrary propositions you don't
doesn't a sentence could say that this
sentence is false it creates a
contradiction within the sentence
without it being a logical syllogism you
like that that I'm merely I'm merely
pointing out that there are ultimately
only two possibilities to two basic
anything that you might observe which is
finitely but they don't what have you
which is either it was it was the result
of something more fundamental than it or
something with that that that is prior
to it
and if you ask well what was prior to
and anything or is more fundamental to
anything either it's something that's
like itself as insight finite limited as
well or something not the case not
finite and not limited so I'm saying if
we go down the pathway of just
constantly insisting on there's a
continual chain prior to this existence
of finite limited things nothing would
exist because that would cause an
infinite regress fallacy went there by
the competition
is manifest as opposed to ultimately at
some point saying well actually you know
what at some point I don't know where
but at some point there was a beginning
of there was something that was not
finite where bride doesn't have
limitations and just to kind of justify
to you limitations requires explanation
something doesn't have limitations
doesn't require expenditure but there's
no limits for it to be there's nothing
to create its limits for it to be
explained by something else
it still so far as explanation simple
observation if you say God created all
the next obvious question of course is
who created God please let me finish and
the second one is as I say you are
talking the language of certainty what
we have learned in the course of my
lifetime is that the origins of the
universe have been pushed further and
further back in time it's a fascinating
study I don't pretend to understand more
than the average man on the street about
it but to say that we clearly understand
the nature of creation
seems to me extremely arrogant and to
pretend that you can speak with
certainty about something like that I
think is good admire they're not
justified well I think it's a little
arrogant to actually dismiss what we
actually said because we never actually
claimed that we know every tiny particle
in this universe or how big it is or
where it began we never actually said
that so it is the I'm just saying that
yesterday just saying that shows that
you weren't listening to what we were
saying and some people might say that's
a arrogant - what I'm saying is very
simply this creation or causation or
whatever you want to cause it is too
limit something to defy limitation that
when you draw a circle drawing a
limitation so limitations require
explanation but if something has no
limitation then there's nothing that
requires it to be determined cuz it has
no there's not there's no boundaries
that existed it is it is fundamentally
unlimited positive necessary being and
say it doesn't require it I didn't say
necessary I said but that's the opposite
of limited no because limitations
require explanation not not black
they're off and limitation as opposed to
what what was the positive not not being
limited and what is something what is
something that's not limited it's
necessary because if it's not necessary
that it's limited what's for the
functional necessary cuz you keep using
it incorrectly what's your understanding
or necessary existence well you know you
were talking about contingent things
it's the opposite of that something you
give it something that cannot have been
differently and there's no explanation
for it
what outside of itself well I suppose
okay so can you can you can you tell us
how there can be a world with no
necessary existence well who says well
you said we're living in a world of
possible or you said that we have to
claim that we're living in a world of
possible existence is you do you agree
that there could be a explain that do
you accept that there is a necessary
existence I would say that yes then
that's good that doesn't have to that
does not it does not have to be here for
us a necessary existence is something
which is this is the perfect couldn't be
another way explains everything else
that's our definition of explains
everything else because without this
necessarily couldn't be any other way Oh
Alex all contingent things depend upon
it yes give me an example the contingent
thing and it's this car how is it
contingent because it could have
otherwise not been in existence do you
know speaking to a determinist fun yeah
okay so what is the term so if if you
said your and your thing sorry what the
terminal yeah yes let me ask you
questions and volume isolated but it
will make sense go ahead if P entails Q
go he is necessary yes is Q necessary no
it's not no no no it's not just doesn't
have to be if necessary so look to me
explain why
what we're doing here is we've said that
these dependent contingent things as
you're defining them do you accept that
this cup could have otherwise not been
in existence no so okay this that's what
to tell it isn't it wasn't do you
believe in the determinism yes and you
said in your you said in your speech in
your thing a universe from nothing you
said that determinism comes from the
necessary existence right yes
forty-eight minutes in you said that one
necessarily leads from the other are in
other words determinism leads from
necessary existence yes or no you said
you said determinism leads from
necessary existence okay I think we were
talking about a different thing no no
you said this and I can show so you know
you said the University says it is
hardly a semantic point scoring exercise
it's not anything different by what
you're no problem but you said this you
said and you said matter
you said determinism comes from the
necessary existence what did I mean by
that I mean two days ago
the guy asked you is the universe would
you agree with Bertrand Russell that the
universe just is yeah and you replied
and said yeah the fact that universal
necessary existence the I would agree
with that in the first instance and then
he said how would that tie in with
determinism you then said determinism
follows from is that which follows the
term doesn't follows from the necessary
existence right I tried remember I was
taught so I was I was the person was
debating with the guy cool camera
patootie yeah making the ket he was
making the case with the contingency
argument right I'm saying that there are
contingent things in the universe and
therefore he was using that reasons
there's a god and I said that if that
were the case yes that necessary
existence the contamination would follow
from that I was making okay so I did
agree minute does it listen Alex I
didn't say that it will agree with you
on that point so this is the thing you
agree with us on more points than you
think you agree with us on you believe
in a necessary existence which explains
everything else necessary existence be
careful as you said and necessary
existence you are you retracting it I
said that the are you attracting the
universe there's not one unified
necessary
you said that the universe wasn't
necessary because the universe follows a
necessary causal chain okay so they said
no you said hold on you said the
universe isn't necessary existence and
then you said determinism follows from
that now I'm saying that okay if I said
that and I meant what you think I meant
by yes I retract it but it's attractive
but I don't think that's what I think
what it is alex is that you people can
go oh so you were very good at making
arguments against things I used to
believe in oh nothing's even it because
okay now it's perfect no it's important
because if you feel changing you and I
have reason why you've changed your
thank you I was wanted so they do
created God yeah well we have to
actually ask the question why does
anything need creation in the first
place right it's a more fundamental
question yeah so I mean I could take
this clock but I usually sometimes I
just take a stone or something and I say
how do you know that this actually think
was create over quite it to be quite a
creation so if this thing was let's say
eternal or let's say uncreated then why
is it in this particular shape form and
so on so forth that it didn't to choose
if something was uncreated and nothing
determined its limitations then it
wouldn't have limitations which is my
point so therefore it's it's it's kind
of ridiculous to argue that God requires
creation when he has no limits that
require defined by anything to be
defined by all determined by something
else and that's why we know that
anything is created it's only because it
has limitations how long do you think
God's being around for eternity
well okay what I'll say is that they you
know God is outside of time so there's
no there's no pre-existent time before
him right he's the beginning how do you
know but but I you know what what kind
of just you mention you mentioned in
your presentation I just want to just be
touching it before we do anything else
which is you said that Islam is
terrified of of a people professing
atheism alright again I think that's I
don't know what experience you've had
maybe with from reading European history
books but I said I suppose you should
read books from about Mesopotamia and
it's time I say
five million that's like if I may just
finish I'll let you respond so the
Prophet Mohammad Ahsan had a famous
debate with a Bedouin atheist right
there was no intolerance there the bet
did Betty when I first became Muslim but
there was no intolerance just because
the guy initially profess to be atheist
um Abu Hanifah famous classical scholar
in medieval Iraq Baghdad actually had
public open air debate with atheists
presumably there's atheists were living
in Baghdad all the time to actually be
invited to open air debates and no one
killed them all was intolerant to them
at all whatsoever and when you say Oh
Islamist is terrified of atheists I just
want to say something you're not special
we encounter polytheists we encounter
Christian Tura Trinitarians we encounter
zoroastrians for our history and from
our perspective you're all arguing
exactly the same thing which is somehow
the the finite thing is this is also
infinite eternal and we don't really we
don't really see you as different
actually you're just an just another
yeah yeah it's not a flavor of ice cream
that we are basically encountering so I
don't don't make yourself out to be what
else more special than you are from the
our perspective and as for their issue
of tolerance of atheists I think you
should question your founders of the
very ideology which pervades the West
liberalism John Locke in his letter on
toleration argued that you should
tolerate different Christian sects
Protestants typically but not yes
because you can't trust what they say
they don't believe in any higher moral
value or then mainly what is expedient
Rousseau made also the same argument and
some people say that under the current
you could say a theistic idea as opposed
to the natural rights arguments of John
Locke but the Benthamite arguments of
utilitarianism really morality is only
based on expediency and then people's
rights are based on whether it's
expedient to the state to even tolerate
your right so then it's not related to
debate itself but the guy brought it up
and it's really disingenuous to bring up
in that kind of debate yes yes I mean I
used to jesting that someone like
Socrates was a deeply immoral man no I'm
not saying it I'm saying John interest
you seem to be implying no no John Locke
said that you that you can't look past a
theory on this earth
all the differences that the things the
things which our world view a bit based
upon which are the philosophies of these
men we can say that those areas of their
philosophies were wrong John Locke said
some pretty egregious things the entire
list how can you do anything the
differences we'll get to that the
difference it's not something that
you're wrong no III think I actually
don't believe it different the
difference is the difference is that you
can't do the same thing when there is
something immoral or even when there is
something immoral in the basis if when
there is something immoral that comes
from somebody who founded the worldview
that we believe in and something else
unrelated ly that he said that no longer
applies was wrong can you prove you
something we can say that we disagree
with or do we have to we can say that we
disagree what he had to do the same so
can you do the same thing you're making
Annapolis immoralities in the Quran you
can't make the same look we have just
allowed you to speak and there were
there were many times I could have
interjected and asked you similar
questions and you're making your to
cooperate fallacy and you smart enough
to know it you can't just turn around
and answer a question for being immoral
nihilus especially since i'm not one
anymore oh you've changed your mind
yours as well what what statement the
ones that you said you're more right now
what do you think moral subjective isn't
mentally and means to me what do you
think or say you're saying you can't say
this because you're a moral subject to
this in tomorrow yeah you're making a
moral clip your father mojo does what is
moral subject yeah so you don't have a
victim or ally it's not for it's not
fixed it's not true or false
despite human thoughts or convictions
that morality is true so it's only first
class yeah my questions had asked one
question then you can answer it my
question is he's made it very clear on
his public profile that this man is does
not believe an object of morality why
and how can you say this in one breath
and then starting passing moral
judgments which are based on liberalism
can you explain how a theism accounts
for that or how it doesn't I say that's
a two o'clock a palace it's not a
different place I see you as well it's
simply saying well you do this too so
who are you to speak that's not not
doing it we are working on it your
worldview your worldview claims that
morality is objective and your worldview
has objective moral statements like the
ones I've highlighted it's your job to
prove yeah that those can be coherent
with objective morality God is
all-knowing God said so that's what we
believe anything God says is although
anything God says it's more yes okay
refute that please
I don't know that's why I'm not trying
to change your mind I'm I'm kind of talk
for the audience and if you want to find
moral precepts within Islam that they
disagree with they have to disagree but
if you have an all-knowing agency as you
have said and said if God says something
is moral then it is moral as that's what
I say yeah and so if the people here
this evening disagree with the moral
precepts of the socialization of Islam
so let's talk about that unless
absolutely how do you know what God said
well okay here to go back to our
argument I said that we said that you
have revelations of full time the final
revelation is the Quran as a
falsifiability test I gave you four
things preservation intimate ability
contradictions and I also taught you
about predictions of the Quran and
Sunnah now in order for you to say that
the Quran is false you have to falsify
it like a scientist would have to
falsify theory for in order for them to
say that that is wrong now if you can't
produce any evidence for that then
really you can't remain agnostic on the
issue how do you answer how do you know
that the words contained in the Quran
were the words that were actually
supposed to have been spoken to the
habit by the angel Gabriel supposing
that any of those in the modern world
can I believe it yeah okay
so first and foremost with regards to
morality it's actually completely
irrelevant in this debate concerning
when we're discussing explanation of
reality if you don't believe in
objective morality then there's nothing
to compare the morality of Islam with
right just say that just as discordant
with it yes right so I think it's a
massive red herring and I think I think
that friend of yours will talk about a
few fallacies concerning bringing up in
the first place you have to first
present to us objective right imagery
and then compare it to Islam's morality
and say there's that they don't they
don't fit can't and that's my point
and also the fact that you say well if
we don't like some morality in the back
in the past or some basis or for just
affirm rights in the past we can change
it well that's what's scary because in
modern was at 21st century Europe and of
what one 20th century Europe need i say
more
people thought that morality of people's
protections of rights and things were no
longer convenient for the nation that
the nation's security and then they
prejudicially in a persecute certain
minorities because it was no longer
beneficial from their estimation
there's no objective basis to argue
against other than you say what I don't
like or find it distasteful oh he did so
that's that is actually scary that you
don't have objective morality because
there's no actual promise of of Rights
that you can actually under right now as
for the well no well yes I mean there
are I mean you're asking a questionnaire
you just okay the restaurant statement
look the subjectivity of morality
doesn't lie at the level of the act
itself it lies at the level of the
motivations I can say to somebody like
we I I am a psychological headedness in
the same way that nil was I can say it
says I I know what people's motivations
are ultimately speaking and I and there
are objective facts to be known about
how to achieve a goal so it's not a case
mile subjective as Mills mill demand
swim all objective is emit more immoral
I said I'm a psychological utilitarian
okay so Terry in like Johnson mill not
just a utilitarian okay well I hope the
audience can notice the difference in
the level of interjection here like I'm
trying to really listen to what you have
to say but you've got to let me respond
okay good psychological utilitarianism
means that we can know what people's
motivations are and I think we can there
are objective things to be known about
how to achieve those goals if somebody
thinks that something is right and I
think it's wrong it's not a case of
throw your hands up in the air and say
it's everybody's opinion that's not what
moral subjectivism is that's confusing
model subjectivism with moral relativism
that's not what we're doing
hold on those are not the same thing
that can respond alright so Mill in
Chapter four of his book on
utilitarianism he actually gave us an
exact way of identifying what he called
the principle of utility yes and through
that he talked about desirability and
how when you see that something is
desirable for someone then that is it
that is an evidence that it's something
which sport to be done okay now hold on
you can check I've just given you a
reference yeah you're injecting me as I
am because I saw into the title the
title I didn't say the audience can
notice I'm not interjecting I said any
owners can notice the disparity in it
actually needed in the interaction here
is the title of that chapter there was a
reason why the title that chapter yeah
it's not the proof of utilitarianism it
is it is not it's like the title now
it's a book the title of that chapter is
the kinds of proofs to which
utilitarianism is susceptible of the
chapter is proof of your
it's not you get you can check it now
okay it is the types of proof that
utilitarian is which is acceptable to
John Stuart Mill wrote the book himself
you can get the copy from Waterstones
now everyone in the area can google it
yes it's actually the title is proof of
your talent our chapter four that's what
people call it that's not what mill
wrote no who calls at its height mill
mill that no no you say mill doesn't
call it the proof utilitarian that's
what it's title he avoids it he does not
sin name of the chapter mice not the
name of the Jat [__] get up yeah if
you like to okay so I know it's got you
terian is amazing it's a good why that's
important the reason no I
okay so just consumer easy right it's
not movers oh okay I can see that point
of view if he's right I can see this
because I don't care if you're right or
wrong about that it the thing that
matters is the point that he was making
and the point that he was making is that
you can't prove utilitarianism because
he's a moral nihilus in a sense but he
said that there are certain proofs to
which I'm prove it why me okay so
because you can't prove that the point
of mill maybe so it's a subjective the
point of the mill mate was a visible
thing which you brought up is that the
only evidence we have that something is
visible is that it can be seen that's
what you said now we we can't prove okay
there's some proof visible and we can
use the same reason to understand more
okay it's not one thing it's an end up
one thing for someone who said that
there are many things that you know you
don't know in the universe and things
that you can't presume yes for you to
claim that you now know people's
motivations with the same kind of
certainty enough to make it but it
derives an objective moral system yes
it's somewhat of a contradiction there
because everyone's motivations might be
unique or different yes unknowable to
you anyway certainly we never understand
the viewpoint of a psychopath of Israel
who has the inability to empathize yeah
but look the study of course but to make
a claim that basically that you can
understand everyone's motivations or
there is some kind of unique template of
motivations that all human beings
subscribe to or
kind of can fit into is really
convicting what you said early one
saying that you don't actually know you
don't make claims to know things which
you don't directly about I make those
and I also didn't say I do I do make
more I'll see that that's not a problem
I never said that I didn't I also didn't
say that I don't make morality is it I
also didn't say that you have to see
things to be able to prove them
oh okay so are the illusionary for you I
would agree with that statement and
right I'm agreement I'm still waiting
for an answer to my question how you can
possibly be sure that what are supposed
to be the words spoken by God or rather
by the angel Gabriel pointed out to
Mohammed are actually the words spoken
if indeed they were spoken at all okay
so a couple days ago I presented a
lecture on how do we know Islam is true
when there's so many different let's say
couldn't conflicting or competing belief
systems in essence from every aspect
from the deployment concept of God being
a main issue which is what my
presentation was trying to focus on the
Islamic concept of God is almost
completely unique to Islam with the
possible exceptions of variations of
Judaism and philosophers who've you know
reflected upon the possibilities of what
could exist and what create all
existence and they've all come to the
same conclusion just like good old the
Greek Gunnarsson often is that they must
be an ultimate craters infinite and he's
unlike created things nothing is a
famous Greek philosopher who believed
that if he rejected polytheism and
rejected idols that look like human
beings saying if a cow had a God it
wouldn't make the the gods to look like
a cows so he didn't he was an atheist he
just rejected polytheism and so we would
basically kind of siloed that view but
there's something a very specific
question yeah about yes what the angel
Gabriel is supposed to have said just to
Muhammad how can you possibly know how
can anybody possibly know that that was
actually what happened how and if I let
me just finish my point which is Islam
is basically if you when I encountered
it I encounter
and I took it as a hypothesis for how to
explain reality as one possible
hypothesis after looking at different
belief systems including or lack thereof
and let's say atheistic positions and
belief system naturalism or materialism
communism and such and such I basically
you know found contradictions and things
that didn't make sense and it kind of
almost had a process of elimination that
Islam was the only one left that
actually didn't suffer internal
conditions both compared to the
observable reality as well as within
itself and that's very tough thing too
it's a very tall order to actually
achieve if you're not explaining what
everything quite literally everything so
oh and caveat not the particularity zuv
things like you know how quarks and
bosons in case you actually say oh I
don't you're claiming to explain
everything no but what I am what I
notice is that Islam was the only one
left and then after further
investigation after I thought maybe it
could have been a different way maybe if
one particularly silent auction didn't
exist or if it was a different way and I
realized that that produces
contradictions to the point that I came
to the conclusion that Islam was the
only possible explanation to explain
reality which is why I was very thrilled
to do this debate in the first place but
you know but without going to things
like the you know hell's existence and
all this other stuff the main key
selling point users who say oh of Islam
of the hypothesis of Islam except in
reality was its concept of God which is
almost virtually unique to itself and
it's just rationally consistent and
coherent I didn't ask you about Islam's
concept of God I asked you very
specifically about how you can possibly
know that the concept of God whatever it
is that emerges from the Quran can have
been dictated to Muhammad by the angel
Gabriel I take it therefore that you
cannot answer that question
thank you well it's kind of like the
equivalent kind of challenge or you'll
say me now we can discuss how do we know
the mess the messenger that related the
message is how do we know from from
analysis of that that it's accurate but
I wanted just to kind of that's what I'd
like to know I know I know and I want to
do a kind of a different angle to
that question which is what got me into
Islam in the first place well that's
right different there let me finish sir
well go me into Islam in the first place
wasn't me
looking at the claims or trying to go
back in the time machine to find out if
the problem have existed all the angel
Gabriel came to him I looked at the
message itself and the consistency of
the message itself with the universe I
came again led me to a conclusion that
they both come from the same author and
that's why I became Muslim in other
words you can't possibly know we'll
leave it to the audience to gentleman in
the middle
the word of reality in the proposition
is very big word I think he might be
productive to discuss five of reality
interesting phrase it goes begets not
nor has we go now that honesty raises
for adjustments about believers I'm
going to see nobody in this room denies
the life forms have over time in the big
question is was an agency behind that
and speaking focuses is faulty
okay so there's two questions there do
you agree with the theory of evolution
okay
so do I believe this agency behind it
okay okay so so in essence as Muslims we
don't dispute what we observe from the
universe the Quran tells us to observe
the universe and to understand the how
how God instituted things the mechanisms
God put in place to bring things about
so that's not a problem and we have no
issue we have no truck with animal
evolution and evolution of what we see
my quadratic life and things like this
there's no problem like this and
changing but now for you to claim that
the process of copying and mutation that
occurs which to claim and call it faulty
copying is actually making an assumption
of teleological of Telos as the Greeks
would say of intention that life has an
intention to create perfect copies
alright but if you if a person is a
materialist let's say that you say that
all things happen out of necessity right
things just occur out of necessity and
what I'm positing or what we would let's
say view it as everything that happens
all the mechanisms in life as well as in
inanimate objects throughout the
universe inanimate matter let's just say
all these mechanisms have been
instituted by God so there's no problem
or conviction that we have with that at
all whatsoever
wherever the case might be wherever the
science reveals all mechanisms were
instituted by God yes let's have one
question one answer yes
could you speak up a bit which was that
atheists aren't special and that Muslims
have been debating Christians and Jews
or Zoroastrians for years I come from a
Muslim hands arrest really family I'm
sure the local Catholics they're all
Hindus were Jews thing is with Islam and
atheism is Islam make some flames and
atheism says we're not making claims
with Islam and Christianity or Islam and
Judaism Islam is making a claim
Christianity is making a different claim
Judaism is making a different claim they
all evolved at different times Islam and
Christianity in Judaism all make a
similar claims but there are significant
differences which are of a nature that
is very very important for Muslims in
that for Islam to be true it has to be
able to show that say Christian claims
well say Jesus being the Son of God on
true so rather than attempting to argue
against atheism how do you propose to
suggest that Islam is right that the
Quran is right yes on this side of the
house there are two leaps of faith you
ask God the second he's not God okay so
we've already shown from first
principles how it can be conceived or
can be reasoned that unnecessary
existence which all other existence
depend upon exists and is in fact
necessary for existence but in terms of
the specific claim of Islam I'll repeat
the challenge and obviously there are
people in the audience here I've said to
you before and I'll say again that Islam
makes specific claims and challenges
which are not found in other texts and
this makes Aslam and its texts open to
falsifiability
for example number one is the
preservation challenge chapter 15 verse
9 it says in the National Rosella the
crow in the La Jolla - we have certainly
sent down the book and we will certainly
preserve it chapter 4 verse 92 the
contradiction challenge for you know
Lalaji luffy ft laughs and cathy they
would have found in him any
contradictions
a third the third thing is the intimate
ability challenge and we said before
that this has quantifiable measures and
I'll give you one exam
that Quran was a circumstantial
revelation and it was revealed piecemeal
right so for bit by bit but despite the
fact that the Quran was a circumstantial
revelation and it was revealed piecemeal
you'll find that there is an incredible
knitted togetherness a consistency of
coherence of the Quranic text which make
it almost impossible I would argue that
it would be would have been from human
authorship for example the Quran in
chapter 3 verse 59 says in the math
Allah
I signed the law he cometh alia damaja
l'homme interurban Thumma Kalla who come
for a [__] that certainly Jesus is like
Adam God created him from dust and said
three and he was now notice it says he
is like Adam and if you count the amount
of times
Adam is mentioned the Quran is 25 times
if you count a lot of times that Jesus
mentioned Quran it's also 25 times now
this is one of I would say a plethora of
examples which if you were to turn this
into a probability machine you'll find
makes it highly doubt about unprovable
that this could have been done from
someone who is being asked questions and
answering in the form of revelation the
fourth thing I mentioned was to predict
the predictions of the Quran so for
example the fact that the Quran in
chapter 30 verses 1 to 6 predicts that
Rome would be the Roman Empire beat the
Persian Empire from 6 to 9 years and we
have corroborating evidence from this
from non Islamic sources for example
Theo fears in the 9th century writes
this down and so on now the thing is if
you find all other this is my claim my
claim is if you look at all other
religions world religions if our
predictions are made I will be able to
find you and it's a challenge I'll put
out there for everyone I'll be able to
find you a false prophecy from the major
world religions if someone claims to be
a fortune-teller Nostradamus Charles
Russell from the you know whoever it may
be those individuals made a series of
predictions some of which came true some
of which did not now what I'm saying is
quite bold I'm saying that the Islamic
position is you will not be able to find
one thing that the Prophet of Islam or
the Quran says will come true that does
not come true and from that we predicate
our cosmological understanding that ok
the hereafter which is something we
can't see just like the futures
unseeable is also going to be actualize
materialized in the same way that
everything else has so we have
falsifiability test
this falsifiability test is not in other
scriptures and in order for you to
disregard or discard the Quran and the
Sunnah you first have to go through the
process just as a scientist would of
falsifying our claims thank you I mean
I'd rather brisk move on to other
questions but I don't think that I'd say
internal consistency is certainly
required to say that the Quran as a cure
but it's not a sufficient ya set for
things tells one yeah okay I would agree
with actually yeah I don't think you
actually responded properly to that
question which is how can you how can
you demonstrate but what is written in
the Bible for example is not true when
if what's written in the Quran
contradicts it I gave as an example in
my address the Islamic view that it was
not Jesus who died on the cross how can
you possibly prove that how could you
know it even if even if it were even if
it were so how can you possibly prove it
how can you claim that anything like
that it can be known with certainty and
how can you show that the people who
reported in the in the in the Bible were
a rock you prefer can I save the record
I I don't I don't think that's necessary
to do because I have to be very capped
with a burden of proof here which is
then the the proof nice lie with person
making the claim right the Christians
claim that Jesus died and was risen they
need to prove that the fact that I can't
disprove it doesn't mean that I can't
have a case against it I wouldn't know I
mean I don't I don't think that the
Christian claim is necessary any more
credible than the Islamic one I don't
think they could they're the Christians
can prove it either that's what they
believe but I don't think you could you
could disprove it or or give a credible
opinion one way or the other
what I would say is Sony in science
there's many hypotheses and hypotheses I
suppose is a protection or a claim based
on
previous theory and people like to check
out the claim to see if they are
consistent with what they can observe so
I don't I never had a problem with
actually checking out someone's claims
and seeing if there was a any proof and
also if there was if it was internally
consistent and my claim against
Trinitarian Christians with all due
respect to any Trinitarian Christian
hickel's isn't they're not represent on
this power of course is that I believe
that it has internal contradiction
between infinite immortal God and a
finite mortal man who is also gone at
the same time as well as belief in one
and God is one and three at the same
time and the crucifixion is really
inconsequential to that matter cause
it's just a historical happenstance or a
claim over happenstance but I suppose
really and just to kind of answer that
that person's point in an unloaded and
very very briefly if I may be permitted
is upon the question of discussion of is
their burden of proof the burden of
proof on Arce's but I'm proving them and
they're not saying you're making any
claim so this isn't the better proof
meant to be only on us I would say that
everyone here has a burden of
explanation an explanation of reality at
least ultimately right citing the whole
point about science is to try to seek to
chip away at reality to uncover a local
explanation for things but we're talking
about an ultimate explanation things and
I'm gonna make a very strong claim which
is that only that the idea of an
infinite thing which has will that can
initiate by choice is the only possible
ultimate explanation for all things that
avoids contradiction any other
possibility possesses contradiction
right including an explanation of
reality that does not require God any
any more the prospect does not make
sense other than an infinite power and
world creator and that's my claim and
the only thing and my proof of that is
it's only one avoids contradiction and
yet explains reality okay
one to two-minute closing statements and
starting with okay well can start with
happy to do it would be very brief
there's an old Russian proverb that says
it is good to know the truth but it is
better to be happy and
when you're talking about reality
reality can be very unpleasant religion
is very bad for talking about reality
but it's quite good for talking about
happiness
so if happiness is more important to you
than truth then Islam like any other
religion can protect you against it
against reality otherwise I suggest you
stick with reality may be unpleasant but
it is actually what should guide you
both sides thank you very much for
attending and I look forward to maybe
future discussions with all of you so
I'll just kind of finish off by saying
that I don't think my arguments have
been my fault
kind of problems I have posed to
atheists to have been it kind of
addressed the explanation for change
matter finitude and specificity these
things haven't been explained if this
moment depended on an infinite amount of
pre-existing moments with no beginning
no start point then we wouldn't get to
this point and of course there is a
start point then the question is what's
making this starting thing begin the
chain of call or creation or causality
or whatever will continuously whatever
you want to call it well if it's
something else then it's not the first
thing so if it's initiating then it can
only do so out of choice and that's the
only explanation avoids any
contradictions and I think I've kind of
finish up by saying that I'm glad that
science wasn't invoked necessary on
either side to prove either side's point
but I will say this is just a slight
kind of interesting observation in the
Quran commands Muslims to observe the
world to see how God made and instituted
things and Islamic science while science
within Islamic civilization flourished
because of it with the Islamic
scientists ITIN the Quran as their
motivation to understand God's will more
the second holy book of Islam the
universe that I out of Allah but there's
no command and atheism to do so in fact
you could be a solipsist a nihilist or
an existentialist and not believe
there's even an external reality in the
first place so I think with atheism is
not a question of of you know
some is attached to science provided
that atheism can't even justify an
external reality to even investigate in
the first place whereas Islam is a short
of one okay you can you can also be an
atheist and a horse rider they have
nothing to do with each other
atheism doesn't entail certain beliefs
and like that you don't you can be a
solipsistic atheist but you don't have
to be a solipsistic atheist your rights
say that the issues that we that you
bring up especially the four points you
make haven't been addressed perhaps they
could have been if we could have gone to
the end of a sentence but I think that
likewise the challenges that I proposed
that my opening statements weren't fully
address the problems of morality and I
hate I'd hate to compel or expect you to
do so now in a closing statement that
would be unfair but I hope that it
hasn't escaped people that that hasn't
been discussed and I think one of the
reasons for that is because it can't be
justifiably addressed although certainly
mr. Jabez has tried to honor to two
channels so you should go and listen to
what he has to say I just have to say
that appeals to to the fact that for
instance you say you know that America
had had laws that said you could get
married at ten it's like yeah America
was wrong and so was your prophet like
the difference is that whilst we can
progress morally as a society if we if
we base it upon constitutions and say
that the the moral issues that are
infused within them don't depend on the
person who's saying it or the fact that
it comes from God that's a hell of a lot
easier than when you come up against the
moral at the possibility for moral
progress with statements that come from
the unalterable Word of the Divine
creator at the universe and that's why
I'd probably leave he had to I want to
say okay let me add - you said want us
to here's what I wanna say ladies and
gentlemen you see this is the reality of
atheism where you have a claim first of
all from a nihilist someone who does
epistemological nihilist and existential
- a moral nilus someone who does not
believe in value judgments saying you're
right and you're wrong that's unfair and
it's unsubstantiated that is an active
claim that has not been able to show
from first principles you see the thing
is with atheists they like to make
claims that they
substantiates he said himself who can be
an atheistic solipsist which means you
can by the way what that means is you
can believe you're living in a matrix
world so if you can't even prove the
external reality or even an absolute
reality or even that rational faculties
are truths reliable then why are you
making a claim that atheism or trying to
suggest that atheism potentially is
better than it is slamming in
understanding reality if you don't make
that claim then you're conceding that
Islam offers something whereas atheism
by virtue of the fact offers nothing and
to be honest with you I have to say I
have to say I am actually convinced you
know I have some doubts after this
debate there's some skepticism I doubt
the existence of atheism for atheists
because if a theist
now seriously because if a theist means
someone who's lacking or disbelieving in
God what is a God a God is an object of
worship what is worship worship is
ultimate obedience to an entity and I
don't believe that any human being is
not ultimately obedient loving
submissive to anything fact like
Abdullah said there polytheist that's
what the Quran says chapter 39 verse 29
Allah says in the Quran
[Music]
Oh chi-su Navarro Jocelyn neeraja yes
Joey masala & Handling
when Axl
on in a Canadian
eatin some and opium iti yi-dao become
deaf Justin get along ERT mischievously
yeah ladies a teenager and well-meaning
caffeine so allah subhanaw taala says in
the quran he says not a belong metal and
Allah has struck a parable rajala fe
should I care a man who has many
different slave masters what are jewel
and Salomon neeraja and another person
another man with only one slave master
are they the same in comparison with
each other
alhamdulillah praise be to Allah well
axillary al-amin nay most of them do not
know you're gonna die ie prefer Muhammad
and they are gonna die then you will be
presented to Allah disputing with one
another
I am the day of judgement Laden says and
who is more oppressive than the one who
denies God's science and persistently
denies his evidences when they are
presented to him is there not in the
Hellfire a resting place for the
oppressors atheists have many gods
Muslims are just telling atheist to
redirect their veneration admiration and
their worship instead of to the many
gods to the one God and that that is our
case and thank you very much for
listening
[Applause]
thank you everyone for coming
it's your long night a very enjoyable
one
thank you very much if you believe that
you are done thank you you're going to
do here thank you that's - wait you
answer my question no no no because I'm
sure
[Applause]